voici les deux éleveurs qui
représenteront l'indre et le grand noir
du berry au concours général
et voici delphine une femelle d'un peu
moins de 3 ans championne de france de
la race voilà c'est la championne 2010
est des poulinières suitées qui va donc
aller à paris donc je les rentre est là
depuis une dizaine de jours pour 20 15
ça lui fasse pas un choc thermique au
niveau de la température et sa mère
sierra de ron a fait les concours
d'utilisation jusqu'à 6 ans et à deux
ans elle était championne de france en
donc en 2008
en fait j'en ai eu j'en ai eu quand même
quelques unes qui ont été championnes de
france à commencer par sa grand-mère que
j'avais acheté donc en 1990 et je crois
que c'est à 4 ans elle était déjà
chantôme de france
son propriétaire michel huberson et
éleveurs et qu'un est apte au concours
général
il sera en compagnie de culoz ain mais
qui présentera son mal
hugo la halle et voilà des plaques
si michel reste modeste le nombre de
récompenses qu'il a choisi d'installer
chez lui témoignent de la passion qu'il
porte à ses animaux ancien employé des
haras nationaux qu'il a plusieurs cordes
à son arc et pas assez de temps pour
mener de front ce qui l'intéresse les
une chose est sûre il adore les concours
c'est valorisant quoi puis ça fait
toujours plaisir d'être premier c'est
comme quand je fais d'attelage 1 si je
peux être premier bain j'ai c'est d'être
premier
je vais pour là pour faire de la
figuration à la tête d'un troupeau d'une
douzaine dan estampillé grand noir
il est certainement l'un des éleveurs
les plus prolifiques d'une race reconnue
en 1994 la deuxième après le baudet du
poitou
car malheureusement les ânes ont
aujourd'hui tendance à disparaître du
paysage de nos campagnes
on se bat depuis depuis des années on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait c'est un peu se
battre un peu contre des moulins à vent
presque puisqu'il ya de moins en moins
d'éleveurs moins en moins de moyens
également donc on se bat avec les moyens
qu'on a
vous êtes combien au sein de
l'association je crois qu'on est autour
de 80
quatre-vingts adhérents de toute la
france de toute la france aujourd'hui
sept races d'ânes sont reconnus en
france et seront présentes au concours
général pour des démonstrations destiné
à séduire les visiteurs
il n'y a pas de compétition les animaux
présentés sont les meilleurs de leur
catégorie et leurs éleveurs espèrent
surtout séduire le public afin de
pouvoir maintenir les effectifs